mark Normand ah geez I work with these
people or I did that's a little awkward
boy I'm seeing a lady now it's not going
well not not never been good with the
lady I was a dumb kid was anybody else a
little disappointed when they found out
what abstinence meant i'm rabbina kid
singing sex ed class teacher was like a
kin f sexually diseased you'll get a
girl pregnant but there is an
alternative nose like Jesus thank God be
able to turn it we have something there
is an alternative we have something
we're gonna be fine don't worry
and she's like abstinence I'm like what
is that what saxons what is that what is
it
what could that be sounds kind of hot
what do you think that is what what not
doing it at all this is the alternative
how is it this decaf is an alternative
margarine is an alternative you know
I've never been to a diner and been like
you know on this toast I don't know what
any butter you have a butter I'll turn
they never say yes nothing
it's not an alternative when I was an
alternative rock station it's not
silence it's different kinds of rock
so yeah the relationships not going well
but you know one thing I never got about
relationships are these these guys who
complain about their girlfriend when
it's that time of the month and I go
what did you get a little cranky for a
week did she get a little moody you do
realize that means you're not a father
right seems like a pretty good trade to
me
I love the period bring on the
menstruation I say when my girlfriend
gets your period it's it's that same
feeling like right after you pay the
rent
you know you're like this month is gonna
be fine
love that period love that period guys I
got a weird pet peeve um I think people
use the phrase I don't [ __ ] around a
little too loosely a friend of mine went
down to the corner store it came back up
he was unloading the bags and I was like
uh Wheat Thins
and he goes yes I don't [ __ ] around
you bought weed since I don't [ __ ]
around as a line for a guy who brings a
gun to a knife fight
you bought fancy crackers I think you're
[ __ ] around what does that phrase -
it's like a tough-guy thing we're so
quick to say that I don't [ __ ] around on
a [ __ ] around
I say let's [ __ ] around we should be
[ __ ] around more or [ __ ] around right
now we're having a great time next time
somebody says I don't [ __ ] around say
well you should come on loosen up take a
load off this is why you're getting the
knife fights delay speaking of [ __ ]
around I live in a Jewish neighborhood a
lot of Nazis here apparently
live a Jewish neighborhood I'm not
Jewish people think I am all the time
I'm not I'm not really religious at all
although I do find religion fascinating
it's amazing to me how it changes over
the years like in the 50s rock and roll
was considered the devil's music
now this Christian rock what the hell
happened there
I guess Christians go by that old motto
if you can't beat them ruin it I'll end
on this I got in trouble recently for
using a racial slur and I felt bad about
this you know but in my defense can we
all agree that the gentlest of the
racial slurs has got to be [ __ ] I
know what his name connotation I know
but he's from China he's a man not so
bad you know to me I think the names of
Chinese restaurants sounds a lot more
like racial slurs let's try some you
know can't drive those [ __ ] panda
Kings right now I cannot drive at all
and listen to this one of those golden
noodles just one of my particle
I moved in right next door to me there
one big happy family it's a fun joke I
did that joke in DC and this Asian guy
came up to me said hey I take it easy
with that joke you know Chinese people
they don't [ __ ] around thanks a lot guys
I'm Marvin